continuing this evening with
our weekly reading
and study of the book zadil
the provisions for the day
of the great meeting the great
appointment
from the ways and traditions
and sunan of the best of
servants offered authored by the great
and esteemed imam and sheikh of islam
shem siddin ibn al-jazeera
today we are tonight we are going to
continue from where we
left off last week
last week we discussed
the forgetfulness that would happen to a
person
inevitably in prayer we spoke about the
five
different places or different instances
in the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's
documented lifetime in which he had
led the companions in prayer
and had forgotten
in some way or another and we discussed
the rulings that
imam abdul qaeda
derived from those instances
continuing on with some issues of prayer
he says
[Silence]
says and it is not the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam's way
that during prayer he would close his
eyes
and this is something that imam ahmed
rahimahullah
and others disliked of the folk
and jurists of islam and they
disliked that a person closed his or her
eyes during prayer
citing that it is of the ways
of the jews in prayer yet
another group of
another group of jurists and scholars
allowed it and said it is fine they
agree that it's not what the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam used to do
they agreed that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam did not used to close
his eyes during prayer
but they dis they differ on whether it
is permissible
or it is something that is disliked imam
ahmad and others viewed it to be
something disliked
whilst citing that it is of the
traditions of the jews and their
prayer
and a group of scholars allowed it
and said there's
nothing wrong with that ibn then
tells us what his target is what he
gives precedence to of these two
opinions
he said and the correct opinion is that
if opening a person's eyes during prayer
will not interfere with his or her
focus then this is something
which is better it is better that if a
person's
prayer and a person's focus
is not depleted is not interfered with
by opening one's eyes
then it is better to keep the eyes open
yet if a person is unable to focus or
his focus is disrupted by opening his
eyes
for whatever reason that is whether that
is because there is
there are a lot of
there are a lot of distractions
present or what have you or perhaps that
the
you know that the masjid or the place
that he or she is praying in is a place
of
many distractions or there are lots of
drawings or something this then it
is not disliked in the
under these circumstances to close one
eye one's eyes
he says
he says and when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
would make taslim after he would
conclude his prayer
of course he is speaking about the five
daily prayers
and also the jummah prayer
the jummah prayer according to the
opinion of the majority
these prayers are the ones that have the
following ruling
so if a person just prays
any to recall or praise any sunnin
or praise or praise
eclipse salah
when you ask for rain during times of
drought
or funerals
any other kind of sale salah
this rule does not apply this applies
only to the five
daily prayers
and the jummah prayer that
when the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would conclude his prayer
any one of these he would
seek esther for three times he would say
esther
allah
three times and then he would follow
that up with
allah
[Silence]
i have a a typo here in this copy
he says if no question goes on to say
that after he would say allah three
times and then allah
he would then quickly turn around
to face the believers that prayed with
him to face the congregation
so he's praying in front everybody is
behind him
in the most usual of positions and
after making tesleem he would say
for allah
and then he would turn around and
directly face those who are behind him
this is how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would do this and he
would not
sit there faced away from them
for any longer than it would take him to
make that make those
those remembrances some people
have an idea in their mind that it is
incorrect for a person to put his back
towards the kaaba
that a person turn directly
away from the qibla and so we'll see
some people when they finish prayer
they'll turn to the side so the people
are to the right
and the qibla is to the left or vice
versa
and there is no evidence for this in the
authentic sunnah
the authentic sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
is that he would turn straight around
his back
towards the qibla and his front towards
the people
this is these kinds of things that are
derived
sometimes scholars of islam have an
opinion about them but
when these opinions contradict
an explicit narration
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
mentioning or specifying and knowing
certain terms that he used to do
something or say something
then that is it
allah
it is not for any believing man or woman
that if allah
and his messenger rule
something that they have their own
opinion
or they have their own
opinion to contradict that
decision that allah has made and has
mentioned or transmitted through his
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
so this kind of continues on
some people
are reluctant to
stretch their feet out towards the
qiblah
some people say it's haram haram to
stretch your feet out towards the qiblah
after prayer
if you come in the masjid and someone
sitting against the wall with their feet
towards the qibla they'll come in and
scold them
as if they've committed some atrocity
right
and this is all because of what this is
all because of
something that they have in their mind
that they feel should be a certain way
there's no concrete conclusion about
this and there's no
wrong in doing this some people take
this as far as their house
that they design their house or at least
their bedroom so that when they are
sleeping
they are facing a particular direction
towards the qibla
right side with their right side towards
the qibla and there's no
evidence for this from the authentic
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
and this kind of
this is kind of reminiscent of
an ailment that was present
and beni is and the followers of moses
had actually suffered from and that
is
giving extreme attention to
minutia and things that are differed
upon and things that are
not so cut and dried and things that are
absolutely agreed upon ignoring them
and writing them off as unimportant
what do i mean by that
so for example for example
we have issues this if a man
were to walk in wearing
gold or wearing a gold earring
or wearing a gold chain you know
everybody knows that that's haram
they will catch a lot of flack for
that people
will tell them over and over and over
and over that's haram that's haram and
get upset and make very big deal and it
is a big deal
it's it's a sin but if
we took the same group of people and
someone the same person rather than
wearing
gold or doing something that
was backbiting someone else speaking ill
of someone else
right how many people would
disagree and scold him with the same
with the same
vehement scolding and rebuke
as before a lot less if any
if anybody it's it's rare unfortunately
to hear someone say to another let's not
talk about this this is
this is backbiting or this is negative
where this is
right why is this
because we stick on things that
we feel don't apply to us so
wearing gold is not a problem for me so
i have no problem pointing my fingers at
other people
however backbiting well a lot of people
feel we all do it so i don't really
have any more
high ground to stop that and i kind of
it actually
because i've got a problem with the
person being spoken of etc
this is a big big problem
which is something that occurred
in the time of even abbas as well
when the people of iraq the same people
who
murdered the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's grandchildren
they also would ask questions like
is it permissible to kill a fly in the
masjid
so they will ask the scholars about the
ruling on
killing a fly and the masjid
but the ruling on killing al hasan will
hussain and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's lineage
that's not really a big deal right
likewise
they suffered from a similar disease
they took many of the companions of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
including one of the greatest sons of
one of the companions
they took him hostage his concubine was
pregnant with his
child they cut the child out of her
stomach
and they killed her and the child the
most ruthless
heartless of fashions muslims these are
muslims but they viewed that these
people had left islam
and then they took abdullah
they took him and they butchered him
at the foot of a river yet these same
individuals
would not interfere or
even when they
passed some of the pig farms
of the christians of the area
they refused to get too close to the
pigs
because they didn't want to startle the
pigs of
these are the the you know these are
the
this is the pr these pigs are the
property of the
minority of the people of the book
and their land and they were to honor
that treaty that was between the
muslims and the christians
and that's correct we're not saying that
that is incorrect
what we are saying is there is no sense
of proportion
this is pure hella this is pure
we don't have any sense of proportion
we feel really really bad about
startling
an animal but we have no remorse
to take someone who says
and is the son of a great companion and
butcher him
or kill his child etc etc this is a
disease
right this is the facade of
righteousness but actually it is driven
by desires it's driven by whim
and desire so we have to make sure that
we keep a sense of proportion
a person to face his back towards the
qibla
there is nothing wrong with that unless
they are in prayer
if they are in salah then that is
impermissible
if they are relieving themselves then it
is not permissible to relieve oneself
facing towards the qibla or turning your
back towards the qibla
these are the three instances when it is
impermissible
to turn away from the qibla any other
instances
it is an issue of preferable disliked
and some things that don't even have any
don't even have any evidence for them
and people make a big
deal about them right so people will
come into the masjid
and they'll have a problem putting
their feet towards the qibla there is no
prohibition in the sunnah that i'm aware
of
about this and the scholars the jurors
of islam
do not speak about any prohibition with
regards to this issue
merely conjecture or
something of preference meaning it is
better that we do this it's
better that we don't do this right
so the time when facing the qibla or
turning away from the qibla comes in
is when a person is in prayer they
cannot turn away from the qibla
or when a person is relieving himself
some scholars based on a narration
collected by imam ahmed authenticated by
some
such as
more also mentioned that this rule
applies for when a person spits
when a person spits you know they park
something up or they need to spit
something out
that they not do it facing the qibla
however most scholars view this ruling
to be
in prayer only however others
view this to be in prayer and outside of
prayer but this is it
and as for slaughtering facing towards
the and so forth all of these things are
issues of
preferable what is preferable what is
encouraged
do not come into this
[Silence]
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would quickly
turn away from the qibla and face
towards the people that he just led in
prayer
the congregation what kenny
and then he would face the
the people that he just led in prayer
completely he would completely
fail
and he would not turn to one particular
group or the other he would face
exactly down the center to where he is
facing
everyone equally as best as possible
what does it mean whenever no claim says
and he would turn to his right and to
his left
what's meant is when a person finishes
prayer salaam alaikum
they do the we mention and then they
wish to turn around
as the imam and face towards the
congregation
now when we say congregation we're not
speaking about just if you're in a
masjid
or if you have a lot of people we're
speaking about any time
another person prays behind you even if
it is only your wife or your sister or
your daughter
or you know your mother right
this is you are leading someone in
prayer even if it's just one person once
you're done you turn around and you face
that person
and when you turn around
when the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would turn around
would he turn his ru to his right
would he turn this way to face them or
would he turn to his left the other way
to face them
ibn al-qayyim says he used to do both
and this is something that occurred in
the time of the tabian
that some rumors were going around
that the imam should only turn to his
right
to face the congregation and so ibm
he said the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam used to turn to the
right and to the left
do not insist on only turning to the
right as a matter of fact
he would usually turn to the left this
is how
ibn maserud mentions as was
collected by ibn hazman in
and so the point here is that either way
is fine
he said and when he would finish
the the the break of dawn prayer
he would remain in his area of prayer
until the sun would completely rise
till the sun would completely rise
so he would turn around and then he
would make
vikir and atkar and recite
portions of the quran whatever it is to
himself
and the companions as well after fajr
until the sun would completely rise
this is what his tradition was now there
is a narration
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam the narration is in
that
it is in a sunan that if an individual
prays salat al-fajr and then waits
in the place that he prayed until the
sun rises
completely and then makes two recap
it will be written for him as if he had
made a hajj
the scholars of islam differ on the
authentication of this narration
many of them view it to be an
inauthentic narration
however the action in it
is something that the scholars agree
upon
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to do
that he would pray the companions would
pray
and they would remain in their places in
the masjid
until the sun would rise completely they
would
make two rakha and then he would leave
and some would leave off the turret
until until pre-noon
just before noon they would pray it
because it is a more
virtuous time and that's the salah
and he would say after each
obligatory prayer each obligatory prayer
meaning the five prayers in salah
he would say none is rightfully
worshipped but allah alone
no partners unto he to him belongs all
of the dominion
to he belongs all praise and he is
over all things capable
and able subhanna and
omnipotent and he would also say
[Silence]
he would also say oh allah
there is no stopping what you have
judged to be given
and there is no giving what you have
judged
be stopped and prohibited
nor will intense
trying intensely change this because all
intensity comes from you he says
and there is no change nor
any power or strength except by
allah none is rightfully worshipped but
allah
and we do not worship anyone other than
he
so he belongs all favor to he belongs
all virtue and to he belongs
all good mention
and praise none is rightfully worship
but allah
we say this completely devoting all of
our actions and all of our
worship to he
alone even if the disbelievers
are in disagreement even if they dislike
this
video
[Silence]
he says and he and likewise the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
encouraged his ummah encouraged his
followers
that they say after each
obligatory prayer that they say
subhanallah
33 times meaning perfect
is allah free from any deficiency or
imperfection is allah
alhamdulillah all praise is due to allah
[Arabic recitation]
allah is greatest 33 times
and that you know 33 33 33 makes 99
and the finality of that would be
how does a person do this subhanallah
subhanallah subhanallah subhan allah
subhan allah subhan allah subhan allah
just that 33 times they counted in
that way
this is how the scholars mention
that a testimony would happen
they they mention two types of ways
either with the
thumb this or simply moving the
fingers
up and down in this way right so subhan
allah subhan allah subhan allah subhan
allah
and this is something that we have to
mention and that is
this thing where people
say something or do something so long
that it just becomes
rambling nonsense that they are
saying because they're somewhere else
you know what i'm talking about this
doesn't count this is a person is
wasting his or her time
completely other person you'll see them
moving their fingers in it or if they
have one of these
message you know beads or a rosary
they'll be moving it so fast it is
physically impossible to actually even
think subhanallah that fast it's
impossible
right
moving your fingers this or you
know some people
this person is not doing anything this
person is just moving his fingers
they have not done the sunnah and they
have not left off the sunnah they're
doing some
other thing that has nothing to do with
what the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam commanded
and we see this in in prayer too
people they're not focused on what
they're saying
so in prayer instead of saying subhana
rabbi
subhan just that right
it's meditation you are meditating
everything you say you are expressing
from the depths of your heart that's how
your prayer is going to be of
consequence
otherwise you're just you know
and so a person would make
and say
you know what you're saying you every
time you say it it comes from a place
deep within you
but people you know they learned
subhanallah
when they were kids and as adults they
end their lives by saying
this this is not anything this person's
prayer cannot be valid in this way
it's neither arabic it's some kind
of
you know chance of a magician or
something and so
it's important for us to understand this
if you're going to make the tasmiyah
you make it properly you say it properly
from your heart
first subhan
that's that's how you say it right
now ibn al-qaeda here mentions 33 times
each there are a number of narrations
one and the one that is most common
and the one that is most that he taught
all of the companions when they asked
him
is subhan allah three times
alhamdulillah
33 times
[Arabic recitation]
but also we have subhanallah
33 times alhamdulillah
[Arabic recitation]
we also have subhanallah 27 times
alhamdulillah 27 times
27 times we also have
subhan allah 10 times
[Arabic recitation]
ten times and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam mentioned that this was for a
person who is in a rush
person who is in a hurry some kind of
you know pressing
circumstances
he says
[Silence]
he says and ibrahim has collected in his
authentic compilation on the authority
of ahadith
muslim who narrates that the messenger
of allah
instructed him if you pray
the morning prayer then say
before you say anything else meaning
before you speak to anyone or go on with
your day
oh allah save me from the fire deliver
[Arabic recitation]
na say it seven times how would a person
say this so after fajr
they would say allah
this is after fajr and after maghrib
salah
okay he says if you say this seven times
after fajr and you die
that day after having said that
allah will
will have written for you
protection from the fire and if you pray
salat
then say that as well before you speak
meaning before you go on with your
evening o allah save me from the fire
grant me refuge from the fire
seven times and if you die that night
then allah will have written for you
protection
from the fire now
there's a couple of things that we want
to mention here number one the scholars
of islam differ on the authenticity of
this narration
however there is an authentic
difference in the son of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
between the of fajr and merib
and the rest of the daily prayers
okay what does that mean
in
the fajr prayer and in the mercury
prayer there are additional of god
after salah that are to be
said in the opinion of many of the
scholars of islam
so after each prayer
if we were to collect all of the
narrations
of what the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam said or
did after prayer or advised
be said after prayer
we will come to the following conclusion
when a person finishes prayer he starts
with
establish a stuffed fiddle
[Silence]
okay this is all the prayers then the
person
[Silence]
the 255th verse of the second chapter of
the quran
the prophet salallahu said whoever
recites after each prayer
meaning each obligatory prayer the only
thing preventing him
standing in between him and entering
paradise
is death
after this the person will then recite
okay
he so each one of these three times
three times three times
three times and the rest of the prayers
including jomah just one each
okay then the person will make the
tasmiyah
subhanallah subhanallah subhanallah
in the way that we mentioned the most
preferable 33 times each
finalized with
foreign they would add an additional
10.
10 times okay
as well in fajr alone
a person would add an additional vicar
which is
[Silence]
you beneficial knowledge in my day today
and actions that are
accepted he said allah
beneficial knowledge pure
and good bounty and
action which is accepted
meaning in this day this is for fajr
only
now ibn mentions also this narration
for fajr and merib
seven times each these are the atkar
of prayer
now what i've mentioned to you is
a very common
rundown of the different utkar
of prayer prayers
amongst the scholars of islam there are
differences
there are differences the scholars of
islam have differences
amongst them with regards to
understanding
the narrations and authentication
of the narrations from which we have
collected
these narrations however this is a very
popular opinion the one that i have just
mentioned amongst the scholars of islam
there is no to my knowledge a particular
order
that these
are to be made meaning a person
the only thing that we authentically
know is that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would
end his prayer by estafa allah
allah
we know that's the first thing but the
order of everything else
we're unsure of but then when we refer
back to
general principles giving
precedence
over recitation of the quran as opposed
to any other type of dhikr et cetera
also the order of the quran following
the order of the muslim
we come to these conclusions a very good
book for this would be
muslim the fortress of the muslim it is
a wonderful book
it is a book that should be memorized or
at least the most
relevant parts of it memorized by
the muslims right and the earthquake
so that we know what to say when to say
it
it and it's also translated into
probably every conceivable language
there is
and it's printed by everybody and his
brother who has a publishing house and
so
this is one of the indicating indicators
that this book is
has found acceptance with allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and we hope that that is the case now
some people will
disagree with some of the book and say
well this is inauthentic or this is
authentic etcetera etcetera
but it is one of the best
concise books of ethical for every
occasion
that you will find in current
publication and allah knows best
ibn al-qaeda goes on to say that
allah
now we are going to speak about an issue
that is
often neglected by many muslims
and that is the issue of a sutra
a sutra having a barrier in front of you
when you pray a sutra
is something that is a barrier
between yourself and the rest of the
world that would walk in front of you
and the sutra is something that a person
should always pray to
if they can and if it is feasible
right so there are some regulations for
a sutra
and i will roughly mention them right
now and then we'll read what abnormal
claim says
so a sutra is that which shields a
person's prayer
from those who pass in front of him
while he is praying
and it's kind of an indicator for
my place of prayer
prayer when i stand and pray it doesn't
go on for infinity
it is just between me and the correct
opinion
so three qubits just about the amount of
of space that i would need to make sujud
and an additional small amount of space
i would have this sutra now what is this
sutra this is something that
must start in the ground and go up right
so a chair a table whatever it is
and its breadth does not matter
what matters is its height right
and its height needs to be
about about
the height of
the is kind of like
we have a back to the chairs that we sit
on
well when they would put their saddles
their camels there's a very particular
type of saddle that they would use and
it would have a piece of wood
usually on the back so that the person
could rest
their back on this piece of wood right
instead of having to use their
rest just a chair this is called
okay the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
sometimes would pray towards a spear
that would be stuck in the ground
sometimes a wall sometimes
his camel sometimes
the saddle from the cat camel
and there are narrations articulating
that
the sutra this barrier that a person
should pray to
it should be no less than
it should be no less in height than
the
back rest that is found on how tall is
that
it's roughly scholars of islam tell us
is roughly a cubit
in the arabic language is from the tip
of the middle finger
to the elbow as ibn mandur
has collected in his book lisa and laro
so it needs to be at least that high
so for example one of these tall water
bottles
that you buy in the store a tire of a
car
you know wherever a person is playing
praying right
how broad it is does it matter how dense
it is doesn't matter
what matters is how tall it is and that
it starts from the ground up
this is something that is important the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
has mentioned in one narration
none of you is to pray except to a
barrier to a sutra
that is an authentic narration
however the majority of the scholars of
islam including the four
imams imam
imam malik imam
imam ahmad allah
agree that this is something which is
mustahab
it is something preferable that a person
always pray
towards a sutra and that is derived from
a narration
in sahih muslim which the prophet
s
if a person is to
pray then he is to pray towards a sutra
and if he does not pray towards a
barrier
then anything that walks in front of him
will not invalidate his prayer except
for
a few things and one of them
walaikumuslam
is a woman who is of
pubescent age
now this can be anything
a tree you know some scholars
mentioned that it is
disliked for a person to pray towards
fire
for a person at a campfire or something
to pray towards this fire
cari had
[Silence]
some scholars mention that we should not
pray towards a fire
however all of them agree that this will
not
invalidate a person's prayer but
inshallah there's no problem with that
there's nothing definitive
speaking about that
and so this is these are some of the
rulings of a sutra
when a person prays towards a sutra
anything that passes
past his sutra you know
will not affect his prayer however
anything between himself and his sutra
that is a place where he should make
sure that not to let anybody pass
through
if he can
now this is something that we want to
mention
[Silence]
foreign
you know this is an issue that we see in
some households some people
they take things a little bit too far
and so you know when
when when they go to pray
the women in the house have this kind of
stigma
where they can't walk anywhere near you
know
180 degree radius
in front of a person praying and this is
this is all
exaggeration right the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
muslim was narrated to have made salah
in his you know nighttime salah
and it's so tight in the
you know room of aisha that she would be
sleeping
and when he would go to make sujud he
would touch her feet she would move her
feet and he would make sujud
and then he would stand up again welcome
right so this idea that a person
you know a woman cannot be anywhere in
the vicinity of a person praying this is
this is incorrect
[Silence]
foreign